vous êtes les clients vidéo pour une
nouvelle interview il s'appelle
l'interview sans intérêt sans intérêt
mais j'adore cette musique aussi envoyé
un mail suivant le genre ne pas bouger
les fumées une musique qui fait bouger
ben moi c'est ça c'est ça c'est pour ça
que c'est difficile bien sûr aujourd'hui
bien alors
un terme aux chances d'intérêt vas-y
comment ça va comme lundi
réponse sans intérêt oui s'il a connu
sans intérêt comment ça va tuyau de
poêle
tu penses à kuala
à mercredi prochain mercredi 28
je pense et j'espère que la prochaine
question j'aurais de la répartie ma
rentrée
c'est pas possible parce que c'est
amusant intéresse je te dise la vérité
tu vois ouais t'as pas trop chaud là non
j'ai mis un pull pour faire style je
suis branché mais je suis quand même
vous faites quoi pour les vacances
normalement pour l'instant rien n'est
prévu réponse 60 et rennes je reçois sa
mère soit bien comprise à sion tu
arrives à contenir son fou moi de mes
vacances je n'ai revu lundi voit alors
bien franchement bien qui c'est y
répondre sans intérêt c'est ce que moi
je suis à fond dedans moi je fais tout
sérieux matin oui monsieur nous avons vu
que nous l'avons revu et depuis quand il
n'a pas plu comme ça il n'y a pas plus
ouais comme ça depuis que ça fait bien
la derwent qu'il a plus et 1 740 tu as
voté dimanche ouais c'est bien passé
vraiment de là nous et je m'entends
c'est dingue non ouais franchement si
surprenant après 24 ans quoi
tu préfères la mer ou l'océan on perd
des spectateurs moi mes séances
mes enfants me dire parce que sinon moi
je peux balancer des trucs avec du cul
dedans m q dans ma phrase dans la
réponse si tu veux vas-y tu as fait
faire la mère du cul sais pas je sais
que c'est
pour eux c'est pour choper l'audience
elle te rappeler
non mais j'attends normalement ben parce
que j'avais pas débranché mon téléphone
là je vais le brancher après et
peut-être qu'elle va rappeler mais si
elle laisse un message je vais aller à
fond dans ton truc un laisser aller
c'est un message je sais pas si je le
rappellerai parce que très honnêtement
donner ton numéro ou pas j'ai donné mon
numéro et raisonnée lequel ça vaut pas
le coup qu'elle renage parce que de
toute manière on sait quoi ouais tu es
avec moi
mais tu y crois toi ce truc absolument à
tous tout ce que vous dites monsieur je
vous crois
il a une question sans intérêt mais que
pas de moi j'avais un intérêt man et
vous aimez les chiens j'adore je trouve
ça génial un chien c'est des poils ses
dépens ce n'est pas de céder yeux sa
course a redit faisait vraiment de
fermer le gaz avant de partir j'ai pas
de gaz tout et tout et au laser chez moi
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais
un peu ce bleu